initially what about our fight in our
argument was that
yeah that was that was the last act yeah
i got it yeah so um so what'd you guys
fight about
well it wasn't that it's just oh yeah
let me ask you a question okay yeah
that's nice and sweet not how you
pronounce it but
do you believe yes in man
let me say that [ __ ] you in madison
not on madison let me just get it out we
can edit it out oh fine
we won't but let me just say something
okay because i'm saying it dramatically
and slowly and so then i get hung up on
the word oh it's good though
so far it's really it's wrong
it's a different size dances with
karen's
oh no anything
hello anything anything hello
do you believe in manifestation oh
yeah you mean an afterlife no
no not afterlife in in manifesting
things in your life
i see what you're saying yes i do yeah
you do believe in manifesting things in
your life
i think so yeah to to a degree correct
yeah degrees i'm not like you're not
gonna see me outside of
my house on a white robe and doing some
you know things that cost money yeah
yeah
right right but do you believe that if
you you know
think of something and you believe it's
strong enough right what will happen
again yeah two two uh i got into like
say
uh was it the secret was that the book
yeah
yeah that's what we are bored that's
what we argue about the disease you're
arguing about the vision board
i'm arguing
well look i do believe there is a sense
of you know why i think it works is
because it makes you
uh put all your energy into it really
and it channels you
not chances puts you in a place where it
sets you up to see if that's a
possibility
um yeah and so we should probably
bobby's talking about manifestation by
the way for
those of you guys who haven't caught on
and it's basically bobby believes that
if you think about it long enough if you
pray about it hard enough
things will eventually just sort of okay
well it's not going to get the
likelihood of a degree
at all explain it first so then i can
give you an encounter like not like
if you think about it long enough and
you pray long enough
it's part of it i mean is it are you is
he a little
delusional no no just listen to what i'm
saying like jack and the beanstalk it's
delusional like oh my god
i need to know what that is beanstalk
why are you angry then i don't know why
i just made me
[ __ ] you hey [ __ ] you oh
[Laughter]
that's so true you're good at energy
tagging from movies yeah yeah so um yeah
what i believe is is that not only
thinking about it
but believing it right it's not
just enough to pray about it or thinking
about something
it's literally meditating closing your
eyes and actually
believing it it's happening or it's
going to happen unknowing almost
right it's i think that's different than
thinking about it i don't think you're
saying i don't know
she's saying that since i grew up in a
crunch country club
it sounds like a gym crunch crunchy no
okay country
country club i grew up you know my
parents
had you know we're upper middle class oh
upper middle yeah yeah
not middle not middle not up or right in
between yeah yeah
the transitional period it's a gray area
class so um
you know we have swimming pool i mean
like you know a little more upper than
the middle
yeah oh i want to hurt you so bad
or like upper upper twist go back a
little bit all right
back up upper i went out the [ __ ]
hurt
man so um you know i grew up with you
know when i was 16 i got a car
and she's saying that because i don't
say let me say what i want to say
wow you're go ahead then because you're
going to water down
i'm not watering [ __ ] down first off
terrible i wonder
every day every day relationship make it
work um
so i didn't grow up in the united states
i grew up in a third world country
right and so talking about oxnard go on
i while i do believe in the law of
attraction and i do believe you get
what you give out and i do believe in
positive thinking and i do believe
in putting out an attitude if that's
exactly what you want to receive back
but
right but to to believe in an idea that
if you
if you manifest something that it will
automatically come into your life
does not take into account luck timing
privilege
all of these things that he had growing
up so i could be
middle class a third world in a third
world country in
an absolute you know basically squalor
right
and wish it all i want and never have it
what i'm saying is you don't you're not
taking into account you're not
you can't manifest something that's
impossible well
right so no so listen all right i can
close my eyes
and go you know what one day i'm going
to live on the planet venus
which could happen we don't know that's
gonna happen i know it's not gonna
happen we don't know
we don't know all right
all right all right um but let's just
suppose it's it's the odds of it
happening though
are one in a zillion like being upper
upper middle middle
yeah i still call [ __ ] right so it's
like no let me
say my point though let me say my point
all right so you can't manifest
something that's impossible
okay right so what she's saying is is
that you know if you're
if you grew up in like skid row in
bangladesh for instance
do they have a skid row which actually
isn't a bad place the skid row in
bangladesh that happens to be the better
part
right so it's like if i'm in bangladesh
right
and it's on in in the slums all right
and i can't think to my i can't go uh
manifest
i'm gonna be a bigger hollywood movie
star
than tom hardy for instance wow right
because it's just
it's not a part it's not a reality it's
never gonna happen but you can
right being a poor kid but you know what
i'm going to um become a um
a bollywood star i mean that is a
possibility a realm of possibility
so this kid can you know i mean no one
no one is saying you can't dream big
all i'm saying is that if you really
believe in the idea that manifesting is
what gets you results in life how do you
explain that to a nine-year-old with
cancer
what i'm saying is bad things happen to
good people and good things happen to
really horrible people and that's
people and that's just a chance of life
you can't explain all of your blessings
on the fact that
you think you manifested it because then
you're thinking you're a [ __ ] messiah
of some sort yeah and you do you think
that
you know what i mean like that's a
narcissistic way to view life like if i
just
will it it will come but i think it's i
honestly the way you cut the way you
describe it's like rich boy spirituality
upper upper middle class yeah um
so [ __ ] secret okay so hey we could
have just
i know we could have got them back well
you're right all right there are there
are things that happen in life that you
can't escape
like diseases luck chance timing
privilege right
circumstance right and so it's like but
i'm not saying that manifestations
you know life happens right i'm not
saying that bad things that aren't going
to happen
right you're in you're living life so in
in life
random things can a meteor can come from
the sky from venus
where i'm going to live where i'm going
to live one day yeah i mean
and it could crush me right now even
though i have these grand
dreams but while i'm here living life
where bad things happen all that stuff
i can still manifest the positive things
yeah because those
bring up your mood and make you a happy
person no but they've actually happened
in my life
i mean let me ask you something right no
no not work
no privilege no no let me ask you
something or ever
[Laughter]
let me ask you something i want to i i
wanted to ask let's ask chris cause
no let me just find my point the time
can i finish my point we're just
fighting in front of him
i know but let's just not does not sound
like a fight okay honestly yeah yeah
let me finish my point and then we can
move on okay yeah my okay
oh no forget let's move on oh wait daddy
everyone we're so deep into this you
can't just move on
you can't like this is like going to a
ralph's and let me uh
my food am i not am i the laziest person
you've ever seen again i'm going to say
luck
you think i looked everything that i
have in my life you have natural talent
you've had privilege you've had great
timing and good things have happened to
you and you should just be grateful for
that in saying that
i will this to be that's [ __ ] are you
are you willing things a lot lately is
that the problem
i believe that i will things too much so
she's like because in this pandemic for
instance i haven't really done much i've
never left the house what do you do to
will
things are you like i sit there and i go
and i just
and i maybe you're right maybe it's just
i'm just a lucky guy shut up i have
dragged your fat ass
to auditions let's just
doing putting in the work that's putting
in the work bobby you put in the work i
think i just want you to be grateful i
think
i am grateful i know you are i'm
grateful i'm trying to tell her that
yeah
yeah thank you all right let's let's go
back to christmas
you kind of made up you're right you
know you're right you know i went too
far
i i dragged your fat ass to auditions
that was the line that went too far
that was abusive but you can't get that
out i'm gonna get that
toxic negativity that's toxic and
toxicity do not cut that out
because because i i'm tired of her
looking good in these things i look
horrible and i look like the [ __ ]
all right if you cut that out i swear to
go we're gonna have a [ __ ] problem
and i will listen to it why would they
cut that out she cuts out [ __ ] that she
doesn't like about herself
oh she will come out anyway so let's
regroup let's read every group
so chris hello how are you i think he's
sad
i was so involving yeah yeah so when do
you think that this is this is going to
end are you thinking
yeah we think we're going to get back
it's in the next year or it's a loaded
question
yeah what do you think i i guess
probably well it's already starting up
a little getting better right the
the